moore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la renaissance du cannabis c'est
maintenant j'aimerais vous poser une
petite question ici dans la salle
j'aimerais que vous leviez coup venir
vers moi
tous ceux qui un jour de leur vie ont
déjà consommé du cannabis je vois
qu'elle a quelques-uns qui regardent la
giz 10 alors moi c'est ce que j'ai fait
avant voyez je suis encore là alors je
vais vous parler du cannabis aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que il ya 10
millions on trouvait déjà des traces du
cannabis les égyptiens l'utilisaient
comme un médicament on en faisait du
papier en chine puis au moyen âge c'est
ça qu'a servi à conquérir les amériques
pourquoi parce qu'on nous faisait
beaucoup de pistes des textiles du tissu
et tous les bateaux étaient équipées de
voiles en chambre ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'en bateau de l'époque il
consomme entre 80 et 100 tonnes de
chambre par année il faut changer les
cordages tout ça donc c'est dire si
l'europe cultivait du cannabis un peu
partout même la reine victoria se
soignait avec le cannabis
à l'époque le roi philippe d'espagne
aussi william shakespeare adorait aussi
ça en les personnalités sont nombreux à
travers l'histoire a utilisé du cannabis
au niveau de son utilisation et j'ai
utilisé dans le domaine alimentaire
comme médicament bien sûr on en fait des
huiles effectivement l'huile de graines
de cannabis est très riche en oméga 3 et
en oméga 6 on en fait des farines des
protéines une des meilleures protéines
végétales qui existe et des huiles
essentielles
on a également dans le domaine
industriel en utilise comme combustible
effectivement c'est une plante qui
pousse très rapidement on utilise pour
dépolluer les sols c'est à dire que
quand on plante de cannabis dans un sol
où il ya des métaux lourds des choses
comme ça qui sont dedans ça va absorber
les métaux lourds afin d'assainir les
les terres cultivables
on utilise aussi dans la construction le
ciment de cannabis laisse respirer une
maison et au niveau de l'isolation c'est
un des meilleurs isolants qui existent
voire utiliser comme textile et comme
papier voilà ensuite au début des années
1900 c'est la plante la plus cultivée en
europe et en même temps c'est là qu'on
va commencer à la diaboliser nokia des
lobbys du coton et de l'industrie
chimique
effectivement c'est lé plus gros
concurrents au niveau textile par
rapport au cannabis et on voit des des
publicités anti cannabis qui
apparaissent un peu partout dans ce
style là aujourd'hui ce serait plutôt
une publicité qu'on utiliserait pour
vendre du cannabis mais voilà et ce qui
aboutit au marijuana tax act donc qu'ils
taxent l'agriculture toutes les cultures
de chanvre aux états unis ce qui aura
pour effet de quasiment éradiqué la
culture du cannabis faudra attendre les
années 1990 pour qu' il ya de nouveau
une légalisation médical qui se fasse
aux états unis puis 2012 une
légalisation récréative parce qu'on se
rend compte qu'au final bon c'est
comparable à un verre de vin par exemple
qu'on peut consommer toujours avec
modération
on va regarder maintenant un petit peu
qu est ce qu est qu est-ce qui composent
le cannabis bien joli c'est une plante
donc lé principe actif du cannabis et
les cannabinoïdes le plus connu au ghana
entendu le thc le thc qui est la
substance psychoactive donc ça qui vous
donne l'effet stone le gars qui fument
sont d'ores et déjà depuis les années 60
on a découvert aussi
le cbd le cannabis viol c'est la
deuxième principe actif le plus connu
dans le cannabis il a une septantaine en
tout et c'est le cbd qui est vraiment
aujourd'hui apporte le plus de bienfaits
au niveau médical comme on va pouvoir le
voir le cbd on voit là vraiment il est
il et il aide contre les douleurs les
inflammations la dépression contre il
est anti bactérien il aide les gens qui
ont le diabète
il est anti psychotiques si vous avez
des gens qui sont un bi polaires ou
comme ça c'est ça va les aider à calmer
leurs crises contre les crises
d'épilepsie aussi le thc on regarde
finalement il a très peu de principe
actif qui qui sont pour au niveau
médical et mais c'est quand même ça peut
être intéressant en 2016 c'est la
révolution suisse le cbd devient légal
d'accord donc c'est plus un produit qui
réservait aux marginaux qui le fume dans
un squat ou dieu sait où c'est un
produit qui est maintenant pour tout
public
toutes les classes d'âge toutes les
classes de la population et tout les
ages concerne du cannabis à vous avez
dit roy est superbe il ya des bienfaits
pour la santé mais elle fume fume fume
et c'est toujours mal c'est toujours pas
bien donc on va trouver le cannabis ou
d'autres formes comme des compléments
alimentaires de l'huile n'était des
tisanes ou encore des crèmes comme j'en
ai pris au tout début
le cannabis c'est un moteur économique
pour la suisse c'est au regard rien
construit ça crée déjà des milliers
d'emplois ont à peine une année et demie
que c'est légal pour 2017 les
estimations on prévoit à peu près 30
millions de recettes fiscales
à part à 30 millions de recettes
fiscales
l'action
30 milliards de recettes fiscales pour
2017 ça c'est ce qui est arrivé est ce
qu'on veut se passer de cette manne
financière est ce qu'on veut la laisser
au moins deux jeunes c'est qu'ils n'ont
je veux raconter une petite histoire qui
m'est arrivé
lorsque j'étais un festival il y avait
un stand cannabis est distante cannabis
bonheur qui fleurissent un peu partout
et il ya un monsieur qui vient il vient
critiquer ce que les gens ils font là il
dit et moi je suis apprécié à la
retraite c'est à drogue que vous vendez
la pub olmèques y parle qui au bout
d'une demi-heure une heure il se dit bon
pourquoi pas finalement ils n'ont pas
l'air méchant ces gens on va goûter faut
pas mourir idiot et bolbec qui partent
et le lendemain je la vois arriver sur
le sang ajoute il a écouté ce qui dit
elle mais qui revient transformé le mec
il arrive il dit c'est totalement dingue
ça fait quinze ans que j'ai dès samedi
ça fait 15 ans que je ne dors pas la
nuit que je me réveille le matin je suis
de mauvaise humeur sa femme et il
d'isère il a dit c'est depuis 15 ans
c'est la première fois depuis où je dors
d'une crête où je me réveille pas c'est
génial merci les gars vous m'avez
changer la vie la vision du cannabis et
c'est ce que j'aimerais qu'on fasse
maintenant tous ensemble
changer notre vision que l'on a du
cannabis si un policier à la retraite
après avoir passé toute une vie à courir
après une drogue a réussi à changer son
image alors vous tous ici vous pouvez
changer votre image dorénavant l'image
du cannabis c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]